[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 22 février voici
les titres
cette action ce matin de la police aux
frontières dans les yvelines la paf a
mené une opération de contrôle de
véhicules al aire de repos de
moronvilliers sur l'autoroute a13 des
vérifications effectuées en
collaboration avec l'urssaf et la ceppm
78 immersion l'assurance maladie des
yvelines justement vient de s'unir aux
restos du coeur dans le département une
convention a été signée il ya quelques
jours pour permettre un meilleur accès
aux soins des bénéficiaires on en parle
avec emmanuel nodé langlois président
des restos du coeur des yvelines enfin
ne cherchez pas de camions sur ce
chantier pour tracter des poteaux en
béton est né dix a fait appel à des
chevaux de trait et nina et farceurs ont
été missionnés pendant deux jours par le
gestionnaire du réseau d'électricité
une première sur ce territoire dans un
instant donc ce reportage sur cette
action ait deux polices de la police aux
frontières opération contre eux qui a
été menée aujourd'hui sur l'a13 mais
d'abord cette information une nouvelle
sous préfète pour l'arrondissement de
rambouillet florence e gilbert a pris
officiellement ses fonctions hier lundi
une cérémonie d'installation s'est
déroulée au monument aux morts de la
ville du sud yvelines originaire de nice
là haut fonctionnaire de 56 ans était
dernièrement la directrice de cabinet
adjointe de la ministre déléguée à
l'insertion brigitte clincker elle a
déjà été sous préfète entre 2013 et 2015
à coutances dans le département de la
manche en main en normandie
[Musique]
elle est principalement connu pour son
aide alimentaire pourtant l'objectif de
l'association des restos du coeur et
plus global celui et cette mission et
celle d'aider les plus démunis parmi les
actions notamment celles de faire valoir
ses droits et d'accéder aux soins une
convention en ce sens a été signé très
récemment avec l'assurance maladie à des
yvelines le reportage de justin brasier
de mathilde franco une convention vient
d'être signée entre la cpam des yvelines
et les restos du coeur une
concrétisation officielle qui s'inscrit
dans la continuité
si le partenariat était informelle les
deux entités travaillent en
collaboration depuis plusieurs années
l'association dispose d'un rôle
essentiel identifiés et accompagner des
personnes éloignées du système de santé
les restos du coeur connaissent bien les
familles qu'ils accompagnent et en fait
elles vont pouvoir nous aider
à détecter parce que les personnes n'ont
pas forcément envie de raconter leurs
problèmes auprès d'une institution un
besoin qui s'est fait ressentir 30% des
personnes renonceraient à des soins sur
une période d'un an au centre des restos
du coeur de plaisir ils sont une dizaine
de bénévoles à être formés à l'aide à la
personne c'est le cas de françois
bénévole depuis une vingtaine d'années
il a suivi la formation en octobre
c'était beaucoup basé sur la
complémentaire santé solidaire on a
régulièrement et je pense trouvant en
refaire encore avec des formateurs de
formateurs de l'asepam pour apprendre à
de nouveaux bénévoles qui se sentent
concernées qu'elles sont comment
fonctionne la sepa et pour connaître le
fonctionnement de la cpam l'institution
a présenté ces dispositifs aux bénévoles
que ce soit l'accès au droit les
complémentaires santé solidaire et la
mission non moi je m'occupe
d'accompagnement en santé et la
concrètement nos équipes vont aller
directement sur le terrain auprès des
bénévoles pour les accompagner les
formés à la détection les former ou un
différents dispositifs qui existent dans
l'assurance maladie l'année dernière
près de 1300 personnes ont été
accompagnées dans les yvelines et pour
parler de ce sujet avec moi en plateau
emmanuel nodé langlois bonsoir vous êtes
le président a des restos du coeur des
yvelines on l'entendait dans ce sujet la
collaboration avec la cpam existaient
déjà et de manière informelle sur
l'accès aux soins pourquoi c'est
important d'officialiser justement ce
rapport avec l'assurance maladie alors
je réponde en d'autres temps on vient de
connaître une période difficile que sur
laquelle c'est pas la peine de redonner
on sait surtout axé sur sept pendant
cette période sur l'aide alimentaire est
aujourd'hui comme les perspectives sont
quand même un petit peu meilleure il est
temps de refaire décoller une activité
importante des restos du coeur qui est
l'aide à la personne et dans l'aide à la
personne ça concerne de la réinsertion
sociale et économique et dans le côté
social bien entendu on peut aider les
gens
notamment au niveau des droits à la
santé 12
la convention qui a été signée avec la
cpam mais parce que les restos du coeur
on les connaît avant tout pour l'aide
alimentaire on connaît avant tout pour
l'aide alimentaire si une assistance
aussi plus globale au début aux
personnes les plus démunies vous le
disiez donc aide à la personne l'idée
c'est de renforcer cet axe là maintenant
de toucher un peu plus de personnes
c'est qu'en valais dans sa si vous
voulez rond sans véritablement les gens
se sont sentis certainement abandonné
pendant toute cette période les gens je
pense ont aussi besoin de reprendre
infernal de repères et donc on est là
pour ça pour les aider et comme les
choses évoluent tellement vide dans
notre vie tous les jours et notamment au
niveau de la santé donc qu'il est très
important que l'on puisse je dirais
identifié des besoins et orienter
ensuite les gens vers l'est vers les
bonnes portes et on est un chiffre qui a
été aussi donnés dans ce reportage 30%
des asturies blinois qui renonceraient
aujourd'hui à au moins un soin par an
comment peut-on l'expliquer on imagine
des freins économiques des freins
personnel est ce qu'il ya d'autres
explications aussi alors vous avez
raison du frein économique fera un
personnel mais je pense que beaucoup de
gens même
les français enfin même ceux qui ont
l'habitude d'avoir accès à la cpam de
temps en temps sont un peu de
désarmorcer disant comment est ce que je
vais y arriver les démarches entreprises
l'ex absolument dans l'idée c'est de
repartir sur des choses simples
on entendit sad en l'emportant gironde
et formation
des bénévoles des restos du coeur sur
les ce que peuvent ce dont peuvent
bénéficier les gens au niveau de la cpam
donc automatiquement ça nous aidera dans
la détection et à ce moment là on pourra
y avons pourra orienter les gens sans
aucune difficulté côté des bénévoles on
imagine tout l'important ce site la
formation parce que c'est des sujets
aussi très technique et il faut savoir
être et qui évolue chaque année donc
automatiquement il ya des bénévoles qui
font ça depuis assez longtemps il ya à
peu près 200 bénévoles au niveau des
restos du coeur dans les événements qui
ont été formés mais là aussi il ya des
remises à jour à faire donc
automatiquement
cette convention est la bienvenue alors
comment ça se passe très concrètement
comment sont détectés justement les
personnes qui sont en manque d'accès aux
soins comment les comment le lien et il
fait aussi avec l'assurance maladie
alors le lien il est fait au niveau du
d'inscription chaque année au moment de
la campagne d'hiver puis de la campagne
d'été nous faisons des inscriptions donc
quelqu'un qui reçoit du coeur ne
bénéficiera pas des restos du coeur ad
vitam aeternam donc il ya point qui fait
chaque année avec les familles et on
détecte au cours de ses entretiens des
besoins donc détection et à ce moment là
si on s'aperçoit qu'il ya des points
importants a creusé assez voilà on
reprendra rendez vous avec la personne
pour mettre sur la table si vous voulez
exactement leurs besoins et
ensuite savoir bien les orienter donc ça
c'est pour l'accès aux soins alors ils
convention aussi très prochainement qui
va être signée avec la caf la caisse
d'allocations familiales on est toujours
dans cet objectif de donner un peu plus
accès au droit seulement c'est à dire
que nous nous avons besoin lorsque des
inscriptions
lorsque nous inscrivons les personnes
que nous accueillons de connaître leur
situation financière alors dans la
situation financière vous avez des
revenus et puis vous avez des charges
donc automatisée des gens qui n'ont
absolument rien mais au niveau donc des
des revenus il peut y avoir des
prestations de la caf ses prestations
évolue chaque année elles évoluent en
fonction des centaines de paramètres et
là aussi il faut se mettre il faut se
mettre à jour de tous ces paramètres
dont donc il est évident qu'il faut se
rapprocher régulièrement de la caf pour
pour connaître exactement les droits des
gens et pour pouvoir bien désorientés un
autre sujet vous évoquiez tout à l'heure
cette campagne d'hiver des restos du
coeur qui va bientôt se terminer on
imagine bien que le temps du bilan
viendra mais les premières tendances qui
ressortent de cette campagne d'hiver
quelles sont elles alors au niveau 2 au
niveau du département des yvelines
j'allais dire que nous sommes hélas en
progression par rapport à l'année
dernière qui déjà été une année
tristement record on est donné ce soir à
plus 5% par rapport à ce que nous
faisions l'année dernière la même époque
et pour votre information l'année
dernière nous avons dépassé les deux
millions de repas distribués dans les
yvelines c'est la première fois que ça
nous arrive est et je pense que cette
année nous allons à nouveau les dépasser
donc on peut facilement dire que la
crise sanitaire a rendu cette situation
encore plus urgent plus plus grave les
plus aigus ça me paraît complètement
évidente et une dernière chose il ya la
collecte nationale aussi c'est un autre
rendez vous très important qui va
arriver début mars pour les restes du
serment donc décide d'en parler la
collecte nationale va avoir lieu les 4 5
et 6 mars prochains
dans 67
petites moyennes et grandes surfaces des
yvelines et c'est très important pour
les restos du coeur dans la mesure où ça
nous permet de de fournir de la une aide
alimentaire pendant ce qu'on appelle la
période d'été c'est à dire en gros de
mi-avril jusqu'à fin octobre nous
restons une seconde si vous avez un
message à faire passer aux yvelinois qui
nous regardent et bien on est aussi à la
recherche de bénévoles donc les toutes
les bonnes volontés seront les
bienvenues elles seront bien accueillis
ils seront bien formés il faut penser à
l'avenir et le site internet des restos
du coeur l'antenne départementale qui va
s'afficher ça y est ils s'affichent à
l'écran pour prendre contact avec vous
merci éventuellement nodé langlois
d'être venu en plateau je vous rassure
alven vous êtes le président des restos
du coeur des yvelines merci à vous
[Musique]
je vous en parlais en début d'édition
cette vaste opération de contrôle dans
les yvelines ce matin la police aux
frontières en collaboration avec les
scrl les crs l'urssaf et la ceppm 78
organisé une action depuis l'ère de
repos de morainvilliers sur l'a13 des
vérifications de documents d'identité
d'employeurs ou encore et de véhicules
sanitaires et sur place nicolas landry
voilà la conclusion de cet agent de
l'urssaf elle vient de contrôler le
conducteur de cet utilitaire dirigeant
d'une entreprise de btp il est
soupçonnée d'employer une personne non
déclarés présente à ses côtés lors du
contrôle j'ai le gérant qui est
contrôlée conduisait le camion et j'ai
aussi deux passagers
donc il a déclaré
[Musique]
on va contrôler les utilitaires donc les
chauffeurs à savoir s'ils sont déclarés
et éventuellement les accompagnent les
accompagnants ont voir effectivement
aussitôt s'ils sont déclarés
de déceler si la personne elle est
déclarée et du coup voir s'il ya du
travail illégal ou pas urssaf mais aussi
caisse primaire d'assurance maladie des
yvelines était présente sur cette vaste
opération de contrôle sur l'air de repos
de morainvilliers les deux enquêteurs de
l'assurance maladie ont en charge le
contrôle des véhicules de transports
sanitaires on vérifie la bonne
facturation des prestations par les
transporteurs sanitaires dans le cadre
l'assurance maladie c'est pour éviter la
facturation d' actes fictifs
éventuellement des équipages qui sont
pas agréés au niveau de la rs connu dans
nos raids ans de répertoire à
l'initiative de cette opération de
contrôle la police aux frontières de la
grande couronne pour elle sa mission
lutter contre l'immigration irrégulière
nous ciblons principalement des
camionnettes de type de chantier qui
sont susceptibles
de conduire des personnes en situation
irrégulière sur des sites tenus par des
entreprises dans le domaine du btp ou
autre plusieurs enquêteurs de la brigade
mobile de recherche sont mobilisés en
appui des agents de la cellule de
fraudes documentaires et à l'identité
pour débusquer les usurpations les
agents utilisent une loupe portative ou
un microscope
par exemple je me mette sur marie ma fac
prénom ça permet en fait d'aller voir si
le mode d'impression est bien celui
prévu par le pays donc là on peut
vraiment voir le détail de l'anc voir
comment elle est donc là on voit qu'il
ya pas de parasites tire pas de bavure
concernant la brigade mobile de
recherche de la police aux frontières
des yvelines une dizaine de personnes
travaillent dans cette unité en 2021
elles ont effectué 117 contrôle dont 51
se sont avérés positifs
on se croirait presque plongé dans un
film d'avant guerre à grosrouvre les
bruit des sabots ont remplacé les
vrombissements des moteurs il ya
quelques jours est né dix a fait appel à
deux chevaux de trait pour tracter des
poteaux en béton difficile d'accès une
initiative guidés par une société dans
monde céline charles voici nina et
farceur et à leur allure athlétique on
peut deviner que ces chevaux de trait ne
sont pas venus ici pour gambader dans
les prés au contraire ils ont été
missionnés pendant deux jours par
l'entreprise et ne disent leurs
objectifs tractée huit poteaux en béton
jusqu'à une zone de dépôt ou en camion
prendra le relais mes chevaux donc on
encolure avec un collier qui les
préserve de tout de tout effort d'être
de difficulté est en fête
on met un on met les poteaux béton sur
un attelage vont rechercher les poteaux
béton et les ramènent jusqu'à un endroit
de stockage temporaire avant quand les
achemine vers un centre de recyclage
conforme vu qu'il ya eu là on peut le
voir le il ya eu beaucoup d'eau il y à
des déserts à certains endroits il ya
peu de passage à d'autres et donc bah là
à utiliser les chevaux qui sont très
maniable et qui eux peuvent marcher
facilement et en plus on a pas de risque
de renversement on a pas de risque
d'enlisement aînés 10h et appelle à
sabots sur terre une entreprise normande
dirigé par louise brieuc qui intervient
dans toute la france depuis 2010 9
cette passionnée d'équitation bresse
elle même ses chevaux qui lui obéissent
au doigt et à l'oeil quand je tire comme
ça c'est gauche voilà ma jument elle
donne la tête et quand je fais des plus
des petits sacs ou cetc droite puis
passionné de chevaux depuis mes 10 ans
et j'ai fait des études j'ai 33 ans et
j'ai découvert la traction animale à mes
27 ans par là je cherchais à travailler
avec avec les chevaux dans
mais pas me concentrer uniquement sur
eux faire faire quelque chose avec
pratique et écologique cette méthode
ancienne fait son grand retour pour des
questions essentiellement
environnementales les chevaux il ya
moins de nuisances sonores il ya moins
de nuisances en termes de co2
effectivement l'empreinte carbone est
maîtrisé mais également dangereux de
biodiversité parce que si on était en
effet intervenir des engins soient plus
créé des ornières dans ce terrain très
beau très beau et très marécageux
première à déployer cette pratique dans
les yvelines est né dix espère que
d'autres projets comme celui-ci
émergeront et puis juillet j - 4 avant
le salon de l'agriculture je vais y
arriver rendez vous incontournable vous
le savez qui fait son retour à paris
après deux ans d'absence crise sanitaire
oblige la ferme de grignon situé à
quelques kilomètres de plaisir sera
présente pour faire une démonstration de
ses bélier de ces agnel et des
étudiantes d'agroparistech sont
également en lice pour le trophée
international de l'enseignement agricole
voici le dernier épisode de notre série
les yvelines au salon de l'agriculture
et c'est avec mathilde francon
[Musique]
annulé l'année dernière à cause du coc
vide 19 le salon international de
l'agriculture se tiendra cette année du
26 février au 6 mars plusieurs
producteurs yvelinois et seront présents
nous sommes allés à leur rencontre
[Musique]
installé à côté de plaisir au coeur de
la plaine de versailles la femme de
grignon à plus de 100 ans créée en 1919
par des anciens élèves de l'institut
national agronomique
elle disposait d'environ 100 hectares
essentiellement dédié à la culture
aujourd'hui l'exploitation des pentes
d'agroparistech et s'étend sur 400
hectares avec 200 vaches laitières 600
brebis et une maîtrise oui ici à la
ferme du bignon qu'à une exploitation de
polyculture élevage transforme sur place
sept cent mille litres de lait tous les
ans
et depuis 2006 l'exploitation s'est
engagé à réduire sa consommation
d'énergie et sa production de gaz à
effet de serre chaque année on mesure de
performance environnementale nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
d'année en année on cherche à
s'améliorer donc on a réduit à peu près
notre impact environnemental de 30 %
depuis 2006 ça passe par des changements
de culture des changements de pratiques
culturales des changements de pratiques
aussi sur les animaux optimisé
l'alimentation des animaux pour trouver
des aliments moins polluantes et du soja
par exemple au profit du tourteau de
colza
la ferme de grignon abrite une berge vie
avec près de 600 brebis de race
berrichonne et romane et cette année
plusieurs bélier et agnel seront
présentés au salon de l'agriculture
d'accord on a une année là une b3 agnel
qui vont être présentés sur le salon de
l'agriculture elle a 12 mois
actuellement elle est normalement
présumé gestantes on en présente de la
race romane
une des deux races que nous avons sur la
ferme la deuxième étant la berrichonne
étant présente dans la génétique de la
romane dans les années 70 par
croisements génétiques entre la
berrichonne
donc races françaises bouchehr et la
roma n'a qu'une race russe qui est race
très prolifique donc on est en présence
d'une race qui à la fois des
caractéristiques bouchehr et des
caractéristiques de prolificité
une vache prim'holstein sera également
présentée par des étudiantes
d'agroparistech pour le trophée
international de l'enseignement agricole
au concours dure quatre jours on a
quatre épreuves on a une épreuve de
manipulation on doit en fait le but
c'est de bien appréhender lavage cette
manière
en respectant les règles de sécurité
âgée de trois ans et demi aux limbes
sera face à une cinquantaine de vaches
elle a des caractéristiques de la vache
quand il ya des caractéristiques
morphologiques au niveau du pis
[Musique]
mais la ligne de dos sic est prise en
compte et après aussi les aplombs de
l'animal qui soit c'est l'orientation
des membres arrivé en deuxième position
en 2019 la ferme de grignon va tout
faire pour monter sur la première marche
du podium cette année
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité le replay disponible
sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile dans un instant
retrouver célia gars de son goal 7,8
culture et il sera notamment question de
la balade d'hiver le mini festival en
vallée de seine belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]